the camp for displaced people in mithush
for half a year it has been home for
julieta carlos like everyone here
she fled her village in the north after
attacks from a group
people here call al-shabab when
i was on the way to my field and saw men
decapitating my neighbors
i started running immediately and looked
for a place to hide in the bushes
after a long time i went back to my
house but they set it on fire
all my belongings were burned
hears terrifying stories like that every
day
he's the only psychologist in the camp
working in five others as well
talking is part of the healing process
it is not only medicine that can help
talking sometimes crying can help too if
people need to cry they should
it helps them to heal to take out what
makes them suffer
for many here trauma comes second when
you have to fight for survival every day
julieta carlos says her family only
received rice and grains from the
government
forcing them to collect grass in the
bush which they cook and eat
eight people are living inside this tiny
hut
and julieta carlos just told us that it
is raining season now and sometimes when
it's raining in the night
there's no floor so they can't lie down
they have to try and stand inside this
tiny little hut and this is not only the
situation for her family more than 6 000
people are living in this camp
under terrible conditions
there are outbreaks of cholera a lack of
basic medications
and food being confined to the camp with
little to do
many are still scared
[Music]
the group counselling sessions provide
an outlet for these displaced people
to voice their problems but ultimately
what
almost everyone here wants is to return
home
in peace
[Music]
today the rights group amnesty
international released a report on the
islamist insurgency in northern
mozambique the report is based on
interviews with internally
displaced people from the communities
that have been impacted
by the increased fighting in the region
now amnesty international's david
martinez joins me to tell us more
about that report hi david what does
your report say about the raging
insurgency in northern mozambique it's
displaced thousands of people
some of whom we just saw in our report
people of cabdelgad are caught in a
triangle of violence
war crimes and human rights abuses
because on the one hand
the group fighters are shooting and
beheading civilians
burning their homes looting their food
and property
abducting women and girls subjecting
them to sexual
physical and emotional violence
including forced marriages
secondly we have government security
forces
who are subjecting detainees to torture
and extrajudicial killings
and lastly the south african private
military company
big advisory group that was hired by the
mozambican government to take part in
this conflict
this company has been using machine guns
and hand grenades from helicopters
so indiscriminately without
distinguishing between
civilians and military targets in a
nutshell
that's the summary of the report david
amnesty international
um accuses government security forces
uh of committing war crimes uh tell us
more about that
there are those uh fighters of the armed
group
who are detained and captured some of
them wounded
and they are often subjected
to torture and extrajudicial killings
and you have civilians as well in those
neighborhoods in the armed conflict area
who are also uh tortured
and you know killed some of them
possibly disappeared
and never to be heard from them again
now
the most american government must
promptly open independent
impartial and transparent investigations
into these
credible allegations as well as others
that are not included in our report
and bring all those responsible to
justice
they must also give a humanitarian
agency
to access to capital guards so that they
can do their work
providing aid to people in need in
capital guard
all right that's david martinez of
amnesty international speaking to us
there thank you david